[Musique]
une stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis allée de chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
un bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 17 décembre plus
de quatre heures de questions réponses
lors de la grand messe annuelle de
vladimir poutine face à la presse et à
la population russe le président russe
qui est abordé par visioconférence de
nombreux sujets internationaux comme la
future relation brousse
washington la crise sanitaire aussi au
coeur des échanges le chef du kremlin se
fera vacciner contre le coronavirus dès
que ce sera possible pour sa catégorie
d'âge la russie devrait disposer d'ici
l'année prochaine millions de doses de
vaccins
emmanuel macron lui ai testé positif aux
copies 19 il annuler son déplacement au
liban de mardi et son réveillon avec les
militaires de la finul à jorda
présidentielle bouleversé en même temps
que celui de nombreux politiques
français et chefs d'état étrangers
considérés comme cas contacts et contre
un isolement l'opposition n'a pas manqué
de lui souhaiter un prompt
rétablissement resocit d'ironiser sur
d'éventuels manquements aux gestes
barrières pourtant imposée à tous les
français
[Musique]
la banque centrale européenne bouée de
sauvetage de l'économie frappés durement
par la crise sanitaire à la bce élargi
son plan de soutien à la zone euro de
500 à 1000 850 milliards la planche à
billets tourne à plein régime mais
quelles sont les limites de cette
politique ultra généreuse est elle
suffisamment ciblé autant de questions
auxquelles l'économiste jacques sapir
tentera de répondre
[Musique]
c'en est trop le parlement européen
demande à la commission de proposer des
solutions pour protéger les intérêts
commerciaux du continent contre les
sanctions américaines des entreprises du
vieux continent ont dû renoncer à des
marchés pour continuer à vendre aux
etats-unis une perte d'autonomie
dénoncée par les eurodéputés qui nuit à
la souveraineté
[Musique]
vladimir poutine a donc répondu pendant
plus de quatre heures aux questions des
médias exercice que le président russe
affectionne particulièrement une prise
de parole par vidéo conférence crise
sanitaire oblige pour plus de précisions
nous retrouvons tout de suite en direct
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
frérot
bonsoir antoine vous étiez donc sur
place et vous avez suivi l'intégralité
de cette conférence de presse que
peut-on retenir
oui bonsoir stéphanie l'exercice de
cette année aura duré 4h30 une
conférence de presse lors de laquelle de
très nombreux sujets ont été évoqués
avec en premier lieu bien entendu cette
pandémie de kovy 19
il était question du système de santé
russes et de sa capacité à s'adapter à
cette crise de l'impact de cette crise
sanitaire sur l'économie ou encore des
vaccins développés par la russie à ce
propos un journaliste a même posé la
question suivante à vladimir poutine
monsieur le président allez-vous vous
faire vacciner voici sa réponse
les vaccins qui sont en circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge est pour
l'instant gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie jeu
mais je respecte la loi je suis les
recommandations de nos spécialistes est
pour l'instant moi je me suis fais pas
je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je le
ferai dès que ce sera possible de cette
pandémie
vladimir poutine a au passage souhaité
un prompt rétablissement emmanuel macron
en marge de cette conférence de presse
mais de nombreux thèmes de l'actualité
internationale ont aussi été abordés on
peut citer par exemple les situations
dans le haut-karabagh en ukraine ou
encore en biélorussie vladimir poutine a
également dit vouloir améliorer les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis avec l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche notamment via le
renouvellement du traité new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques
la sphère navalni a elle aussi été
évoquée avec les dernières accusations
de médias occidentaux qui met en cause
des agents du fsb jour oppose d'écouter
la réponse de vladimir poutine sur ce
sujet je dirais que ce patient de la
clinique bernoise
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
c'est intéressant droit ça veut dire
qu'effectivement que le savez secrets
doivent suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors l'enquêté peut-être
peut-être pas
achevée il faut la poursuivre son épouse
a demandé à pouvoir le suivre en
allemagne j'ai donné l'autorisation
d'état étranger avec qui ils apprécient
négocier échangés le président russe a
donné de nom le dirigeant chinois xi
jinping avec qui il dit entretenir une
relation d'amitié et le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan
chez qu'il apprécie le franc parler il
est vrai que les deux hommes poutine et
erdogan s'oppose sur de nombreux
dossiers mais arrive toujours à
communiquer à s'entendre de façon
concrète
c'est ainsi que s'est terminée cette
conférence de presse au format
inhabituel certes mais qui aura permis à
vladimir poutine de s'exprimer sur de
très nombreux sujets merci antoine
claireaux depuis moscou et pour en
parler de cette conférence de presse de
vladimir poutine nous sommes avec xavier
moreau directeur de strates paul bonsoir
et guy moreau merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors peut-être
d'abord une première réaction à cette
grand-messe en visioconférence cette
année l'occasion peut-être pour le
président russe de ne pas couper le lien
avec la population russe qui a
l'occasion de lui poser des questions
ah oui parce que d'habitude on fait
chaque année il y a deux conférences
importantes il ya une conférence qui est
donc face aux journalistes qui est celle
là en fait et il y en a également une
autre où ils effacent à la population
russe en fait où n'importe qui peut lui
poser des questions alors c'était
possible aujourd'hui mais uniquement si
vous en voyez les questions par email
par internet et d'ailleurs il a répondu
à plusieurs questions qui n'étaient pas
celles de journalistes mais qu'il avait
reçue par ses équipes à côté alors on a
vu beaucoup de thématiques abordées et
antoine méléro vient de nous en parler
comme la sphère nav annick occupe
évidemment le demande assène aussi en
occident
velimir comptines qui appellent à
descendre ex l'excellent navalni pardon
le patient de l'hôpital y prononce
jamais son nom pour quelles raisons à
l'écouter il a dit dans sa conférence de
presse en fait si vous voulez le mode et
les lycées de bauxite sa catégorie la
catégorie d'alexey navalni c'est les
blogueurs et donc évidemment si jamais
il était directement entendu
monde avec petit il essayait de dimitri
medvedev ce la est jetons sont moins la
cote comme moi que ce n'est ce pas ça
augmente dès sa cote par rapport à un
rapport à son niveau lui d'un blogueur
qui qui anime je dirais de je dirais de
sympathiques même assez bas russie
surtout depuis en fait cette affaire où
il est parti en allemagne
il est considéré par la large majorité
des russes comme un traître
alors vous allez me more on espère que
la liaison va tenir parce que c'est vrai
qu'on vous a entendu une manière en
malheureusement un petit peu haché
toujours au sujet de ce cette affaire
navalni vladimir poutine qui dit
clairement
voilà que le patient bénéficie du
soutien des services spéciaux américains
cela donne le ton avec les américains et
en même temps ils souhaitent collaborer
avec eux pour sûr cette nouvelle herbes
hayden oui pas de sourire je pense que
les américains d'ailleurs ne s'en
cachent même pas si vous voulez le
dernier scandale qui est sortie soit
disant il y aurait on connaîtrait les
noms des agents du fsb et c'est tout ça
est sorti par belinga tu qui est un site
internet qui est ouvertement soutenu par
les services secrets anglais les
services secrets américains les toits
donné qu'ils ont dit qu'ils avalent n'y
avait tant les zones et sont des
laboratoires de l'otan donc il n'y a
aucun doute que 7e
cette opération est dirigée par les
services secrets étrangers vladimir
poutine qui dit espérer à vouloir régler
avec son nouvel homologue américain les
tensions un jeu suit minant les
relations bilatérales avant de s'en
prendre à l'agressivité occidentales à
l'égard de la russie câline en
comparaison une réaction à ces propos du
du président russe est ce que c'est le
bon diagnostic
oui de toute manière on a jugé à tort
que la russie tenait absolument à ce que
ce soit donald trump le résident une
erreur parce que les relations n'ont pas
été si bonnes peut-être que les
relations étaient bonnes dans un menu
0e qui aurait parié dès que vous accusez
un peu de connivence avec la russie qui
ont été celles qu il a dû subir deux
2016 de 18 mai tepco donald et
continuelle ceux sortis de texture ni à
d après la guerre froide pourrait s'y
limiter les thèmes antimissile ça c'est
beau chant peut prolonger l'accord start
iii autoriser les accords de ciel ouvert
tous ces accords internationaux qui ont
finalement civilisé les relations
internationales dans des tensions qui
pouvait être grave puisqu'on parle
notamment d'armes nucléaires et bien
tout ça c'est donald trump qui en est
sorti et l'idée en fait c'est que joe
biden pourrait pourrait-il revenir et on
fait poutine répète ce qu'il avait dit
avant présidentielle de hillary clinton
et de donald trump s'était pas dire et
bien de toute manière et voir
responsabilités il espère que la
rhétorique de campagne
du côté des démos les rues sauf va
cesser de vendre la réalité du monde
d'aujourd'hui qui est un monde
multilatéral les américains en plus
intérêt à s'appuyer sur pour la russie
vise avant tout cas tel qu'il le pense
ce qu'il est merci xavier moreau désolé
on est obligé un petit peu d'anthéron
cette analyse 7 things they review
puisqu'on a compris un mot sur deux
enfants voilà on a compris en tout cas
l'idée de cette analyse
désolé la liaison internet n'était pas
au beau fixe merci à vous et xavier
moreau directeur de strates paul
le président français est testé positif
aux qu'ovide 19
il est placé sept jours à l' isolement
dans son sillage de nombreux hommes
politiques français et chefs d'état
étrangers tous cas contacts l'agenda
présidentiel est bouleversée pour la
semaine à venir puisqu'il ne se rendra
pas au liban mardi ne réveillera donc
pas avec les militaires français de la
finul à beyrouth le point depuis
l'elysée avec katia techniques manuelles
maquereau a ressenti des symptômes
pendant la nuit alors il a été effectué
un test pcr ce matin un revenu positif
mais il serait atteint d'une forme
légère de la maladie donc ses jours ne
sont pas en danger
il doit être placé à l'isolément pendant
une semaine je vous propose d'écouter le
communiqué de l'elysée le président de
la république a été diagnostiqué positif
à la coke 19 ce jour ce diagnostic a été
établi suite à un test
rt pcr réalisé dès l'apparition des
premiers symptômes
conformément aux consignes sanitaires en
vigueur applicables à tous le président
de la république s'isolera pendant sept
jours
il continuera de travailler et d'assurer
ses activités à distance les cas de
contamination possible un ces derniers
jours par exemple mardi midi emmanuel
macron avait rassemblé les neuf
présidents des groupes parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale à l'elysée il y
avait là christophe castaner le patron
de la république en marche il y avait là
également valérie rabault du parti
socialiste d'amiens bat pour les
républicains
me jean luc mélenchon de la france
insoumise alors il ne serait pas qu'à
contacter puisqu'il aurait respecté les
gestes barrière en tout cas certains
vont être placés à l'isolément comme
valérie rabault du ps et puis un autre
événement fait jaser c'est une soirée
hier soir à l'est
elle a rassemblé des acquis et chef de
cabinet ainsi que des dirigeants de la
majorité
encore une fois on retrouve christophe
castaner richard ferrand les aussi
françois bayroux ou patrick mignola le
patron du modem
alors pourquoi cela fait polémique et
bien parce que il y avait une dizaine de
personnes à ce rendez vous qui s'est
terminée après minuit alors les
participants qui ont été interrogés par
le point car c'est une information du
point ont expliqué que les gestes
barrières les distanciation sociales ont
été respectées mais ce type d'événement
plein couvre-feu qui se termine à plus
de minuit et demie évidemment ne montre
pas l'exemple
et parmi les cas contactez d'emmanuel
macron à l'échelle internationale le
chef du gouvernement espagnol pedro
sanchez le président du conseil européen
charles michel ou encore les premier
ministre du portugal et du luxembourg
pedro sanchez qui a été testés négatifs
entre temps et pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alexis oeuvre non
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france
le président d'iti focaux vide une
première réaction de l'état n'ont
peut-être aussi de votre part de
l'étonnement non parce que emmanuel
macron rencontre beaucoup de monde un
tout le temps on l'a vu m enlever son
masque remettent une légion d'honneur au
président si sir le lan l'ascendance et
bright eu beaucoup de contacts ces
derniers temps on lui souhaite un prompt
rétablissement évidemment apparemment ce
serait une forme légère de la maladie
donc pas de pas d'inquiétude ce qui
serait bien dans le cadre d'un bilan de
santé du président parce que je ne crois
pas qu'il ait publié de bilan de santé
c'est de savoir quel va être le
traitement que va suivre
emmanuel macron et savoir s'il avait un
traitement préventif auparavant ce qui
est choquant en revanche c'est de voir
que pour les cercles de pouvoir les
règles ne s'appliquent pas ce dîner il
était bien après 20 heures les
restaurants sont fermés mais on a dîné
hier avec les responsables de la
majorité jusqu'à minuit et demi et vous
aviez autour de la table bien plus de
six personnes
donc avec emmanuel macron le voit bien
ces gestes barrières ces mesures
sanitaires c'est faites ce que je dis
mais ne faites pas ce que je fais donc
si aujourd'hui
il est lui malade ça fait beaucoup de
cas contacts autour de la table dont
françois bayrou vous l'avez dit
christophe castaner jean castex richard
ferrand mais les conseillers des lisez
aussi alexis colère monsieur solaire et
et bien d'autres que des hommes autour
de cette table qui sont maintenant qu'à
contacter et puis avant eux
bien sûr les leaders européens puisque
emmanuel bach on les a vus il ya très
peu de jours certains qui se met l
isolement qui vont se faire tester
puisque on ne sait pas quand et mâcon a
attrapé ce virus et depuis quand il est
contagieux
alors quelle image et lexie paulin ça
donne du président de la république on
imagine qu'il y a selon les cas
peut-être deux opinions mais il
n'empêche on parle beaucoup
l'opposition ironise en tout cas sur le
devoir d'exemplarité depuis ce matin
mais il ya de quoi
parce qu'il faut voir que la majorité
n'a pas été avare de petits mots un
moralisateur et sentencieux rappelez
vous c'était le préfet l'allemand qui
disait si vous êtes malade c'est que
vous n'avez pas respecté les mesures de
confinement
richard ferrand qui disait si vous êtes
malade ou bien attention si vous prenez
des risques
c'est vraiment irresponsable et puis
plus récemment jean castex ce qu'ils
disaient que la première des
responsabilités c'est de ne pas tomber
malade pour ne pas engorger les hôpitaux
donc oui les oppositions se font plaisir
et à raison et peuvent taper sur ces
moralisateurs de la république en marche
qui finalement ont fait tout l'inversé
de ce qu'il prônait ce qu'ils imposaient
aux français et voilà un président qui
tombe malade alors même qu'il a fait en
sorte d'imposer aux français un régime
sanitaire qui rend fou pour beaucoup qui
empêche les commerces d'ouvrir qui a vu
fermer des rayons de produits non
essentiels où l'on n'a rien compris
puisque les métros étaient blindées et
les salles de spectacles sont restés
vides et reste toujours vide 1 rappelons
le des secteurs entiers qui n'ont pas
redémarré et dont on ne sait pas quel va
être l'avenir
donc oui on peut vraiment fustigé la
façon dont cette crise sanitaire a été
gérée et de voir qu'aujourd'hui le
président responsable de ces conseils de
défense à répétition où tout était
décidé derrière des portes closes et
sans transparence du tout est
aujourd'hui malade donc on peut demander
de la transparence sur son bilan de
santé sur le traitement qu'il va prendre
et puis il ya aussi cette campagne de
vaccination qui commencent ou
finalement c'est jean castex qui devait
parler aujourd'hui devant les sénateurs
il n'a pas pu puisque qu'à contacter et
c'est olivier ferrand qui lui depuis
quelques semaines a décidé d'ignorer la
représentation nationale député ou
sénateur qui s'est bien retrouvé obligé
en tant que ministre de la santé
d'expliquer le plan on vit quand même
des moments particuliers en france où un
ministre de la santé refuse de
s'exprimer devant la représentation
nationale sous prétexte qu'il a beaucoup
de travail on peut comprendre mais c'est
quand même son rôle puisque on est en
train de mettre en place un plan de
vaccination massif puisque on a beaucoup
de questions sur les vagues successives
sur les confinements sont ils utiles ou
non sur ce virus dont on ne sait encore
pas assez de choses donc oui et mal
macron n'est pas le seul chef d'état
bien entendu avoir attrapé ce virus
donald trump plus récemment mais aussi
ball sonar ou au brésil
boris johnson au royaume uni le
président algérien qui s'est toujours en
allemagne sous traitement voilà donc
c'est pas le premier c'est pas le
dernier
mais compte tenu de ce qui est imposé en
français on attend un peu plus
d'exemplarité de la part de nos
dirigeants
on imagine alexis folin que la manière
de communiquer va être extrêmement
importante c'est un exercice
d'équilibriste qui va falloir mener pour
les équipes de l'elysée comment
communique-t-on dans ces cas parce que
ça peut avoir des conséquences plutôt
positive mais aussi plutôt négative
oui alors on a vu la façon dont a été
géré la communication je disais des
chefs d'état qui ont attrapé ce virus
l'humilité du côté de boris johnson
inquiets s'est retrouvé en soin intensif
qui a fait un discours très court qui a
remercié les personnels soignants le net
c'est ce qu'avait fait un travail
formidable
le retour en guerrier conquérant de
donald trump en pleine campagne
électorale qui s'est retrouvé lui aussi
hospitalisé et qui revient en
hélicoptère dans le jardin de la maison
blanche en danger vaincu le virus je
sais ce que c'est n'ayez pas peur on va
le battre ensemble donc emmanuel macron
pourrait choisir une de ces deux routes
unités ou bien combatif
vu son âge il ne risque pas grand chose
il n'a pas de conditions particulières
il ya une forme légère donc ce sera sans
doute l'humilité ce sera sans doute le
fait de dire qu'il n'a pas été assez
précautionneux à ses responsables aussi
mais c'est rare quand il fait une
autocritique donc on peut s'attendre au
pire
et puis une gestion qui va sans doute
enrobé la campagne de vaccination qui va
commencer en disant eh ben c'est pas
plus mal regardé après tout si on veut
s'en sortir le plus vite possible wallon
tous se faire vacciner le plus vite
possible pour au moins ceux qui peuvent
donc on va utiliser sa les communicants
de l'élysée vont sans doute se saisir de
ce moment là pour en faire une promotion
de la politique sanitaire des macros
depuis le début même si lui ne l'a pas
respectée une seule seconde
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on tenait
en qu'on pourrait être être en attente
en tant que citoyen c'est la
transparence je le disais c'est quel
traitement va recevoir emmanuel macron
at il eu un traitement préventif en
amont est fatigué publier des bilans de
santé
ce que faisait françois hollande avant
lui parce que la santé des présidents en
france c'est quand même un sujet
sensible
rappelez-vous georges pompidou qui
jusqu'à la dernière minute à gouverner
avec un cancer ont caché à l'époque ces
bilans de santé françois mitterrand qui
prend le pouvoir avec un cancer et qu'il
la cache et aussi pendant longtemps
donc aujourd'hui on peut demander
davantage de transparence
compte tenu de ce qu'on demande aux
français et de transparence avec les
lois liberticides comme les lois de
sécurité globale et puis ces mesures
sanitaires qui rendent les français fous
merci alexis poulain éditorialistes
merci à vous et dans ce contexte jean
castex négatif mais placé à l'isolément
n'a donc pas pu présenter la stratégie
vaccinale ce matin devant le sénat
olivier ferrand son mini de la santé
s'en est chargé objectif exposer le plan
gouvernemental en trois étapes et
définir les publics prioritaires hier à
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre a annoncé les premières
vaccinations devraient débuter dès la
dernière semaine de décembre pour les
populations à risque le point avec bsn
chebbi depuis le palais du luxembourg
après l'assemblée nationale hier le
gouvernement a réitéré l'exercice
aujourd'hui au sénat devant les
sénateurs pour présenter les fondements
et les modalités de cette campagne
vaccinale une présentation en sont jean
castex le premier ministre qu'à
contacter suite à l'annoncé de l'état de
santé des manuels macron testés positifs
au corona virus le ministre de la santé
a présenté donc ce plan devant les
sénateurs il est revenu sur
l'acquisition de ces vaccins a expliqué
que le prix allait être le même que tous
les voisins européens avec une livraison
simultanée 200 mai
de doses vont être livrés à la france
pour 100 millions de patients de
laboratoire ont été choisis moderna et
puis files eur dans un premier temps le
gouvernement va s'occuper d'identifier
les premiers patients concernés par
cette première vague de vaccination ça
sera en priorité les personnes âgées et
puis les ehpad je vous propose d'écouter
oliveira le ministre de la santé
j'aimerais ensuite la deuxième étape de
la vaccination tout cela va dépendre
évidemment du rythme de livraison des
différents vaccins et en fonction des
arrivées des doses de vaccins nous
élargirons progressivement le public
pouvant bénéficier en priorité la
vaccination ce sera en ville que les
choses se passeront en lien direct avec
les médecins traitants avec les
soignants avec l'appui fondamentale des
pharmaciens
cela concernera les personnes âgées de
75 ans et plus cela concernera également
les personnes dans un deuxième temps de
65 ans et plus et ensuite les
professionnels de santé du secteur
sanitaire et médico-social âgé de 50 ans
et plus et ou présentant des
comorbidités après l'hiver viendra le
printemps et nous pourrons ensuite
rentré dans une troisième étape de la
vaccination en élargissant
progressivement le public bénéficiaire
de la vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population générale majeur avec une
progressivité ce sera les personnes
âgées de 50 ans et plus
les professionnels des secteurs
essentiels au fonctionnement du pays en
période épidémique dans le domaine de la
sécurité de l'éducation du secteur
alimentaire les personnes vulnérables et
précaires ainsi que les professionnels
qui les prennent en charge les personnes
vivant dans des tentes dans des
hébergements confiné où des lieux clos
puis tout le reste de la population
majeure je vous le disais dès
l'obtention de l'ensemble des
autorisations de mise sur le marché la
première vague de vaccination pourra
commencer à durera entre 6 et 8 semaines
et puis dans la foulée il y aura une
deuxième vague qui concernera l 14
millions de français et notamment lé
personnes à risque
aucune vaccination ne sera fait sans
consentement voilà ce qu'a déclaré
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
durant toute la campagne
le ministre de la santé sera accompagné
d'un conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie et vaccinales un organe
indépendant mis en place par le
gouvernement
objectif accompagner les ministères de
la santé cet organe sera composé
essentiellement de scientifiques de
médecins et de spécialistes
le ministre la santé est revenu
bien sûr sur l'obligation l'importance
d'en temps d'intensifier les tests pcr
et les dépistages 3 millions par semaine
un chiffre insuffisant juger par le
gouvernement olivier ferrand a également
rappelé qu'il était important de
continuer à respecter les gestes
barrières pour venir à bout de cette
épidémie due coronavirus en attendant la
mise en place des premières vaccinations
prévues à la fin du mois de décembre
mais une évolution du virus préoccupante
en france selon le directeur général de
la santé jérôme salomon qui tenait une
conférence de presse tout à l'heure un
risque accru durant les fêtes de fin
d'année en france après une forte baisse
du nombre de cas
puis un plateau une tendance à
l'augmentation est observée depuis
quelques jours la période des fêtes de
fin d'année est donc placé sous ce
double risque d'impact de la météo et
des effets liés aux déplacements au
brassage des populations et à l'éventuel
multiplication des contacts lors des
moments festifs en particulier à
l'intérieur
nous constatons en effet une
augmentation du nombre de cas confirmés
dix-huit mille deux cent cinquante
quatre nouveaux cas ce jour une
augmentation de l'activité de dépistage
avec une progression importante des
tests antigénique le maintien à un
niveau élevé du nombre
d'hospitalisations et d'admission en
réanimation
nous avons encore 25 1182 malades
hospitalisés dont 2808 en réanimation et
1300 sont soixante deux personnes
atteintes du coc vides ont été
hospitalisées ces dernières 24 heures
dont plus de 150 en réanimation
on reste avec nous à dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la banque
centrale européenne bouée de sauvetage
de l'économie
mais quelles sont les limites de cette
politique ultra généreuse et a
suffisamment ciblé jacques sapir tentera
de répondre à ces questions
et puis nous parlerons du parlement
européen qui souhaite des solutions pour
protéger des intérêts commerciaux du
continent
contre les sanctions américaines
[Musique]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise non vraie
bêtise c'est à dire que vous dépendrez
entièrement de l'état le problème du
revenu et recel c'est effectivement il y
aura une contrepartie ce sera qu'on va
supprimer un certain nombre d' aide
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que
finalement les 9 2 millions de pauvres
on a dans ce pays vont être encore plus
haut c'est un espèce de nivellement par
le bas c'est à dire tout le monde à 750
euros mais avec 750 euros vous pouvez
vivre les entreprises on attendait juste
plus la peine de payer 2000 euros les
gens ils ont déjà 300 euros on fabrique
moi là on parle de 400 milliards pour
faire un revenu universel et 400
milliards 70% ont pib on fait comment on
les sort d'où
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
pts est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là ou si je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il ya quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la dent fip et brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population un territoire qui est porteur
de causalité une explication mais des
densités un train si l'on dira
d'appartement il ya des chaînes de
contagion des autos à l'intérieur
probablement milieu familial parce qu on
a des familles qui vivent à trois
générations et c'est tout cet ensemble
de causes qui constitutionnellement un
syndrome en quelque sorte social et dont
le gaullisme est à la fois le révélateur
est malheureusement la cause
déterminante tombe bien je suis très
frappé en rente représentants des
sciences sociales par finalement le
progrès considérables qu'on a fait dans
cette pandémie cas mondialisation n'a
pas que des mauvais côtés en un an on a
mis au poids pratiquement aveugle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1964 ce qui ne
change pas c'est la condition humaine et
une certaine idée de la civilisation se
fait de la dignité de la personne
humaine et de sa liberté si vous aviez
deux ou trois mots pour caractériser ce
que vous appelez la méthode l'attitude
l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non voilà comme
disait malraux seul l'esclave dis
toujours aux heats salariés écrit au
dessus du bureau de chaque responsable
politique en particulier de ceux qui se
prétendent des hommes d'état
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez la banque
centrale européenne bouée de sauvetage
de l'économie la bce élargi son plan de
soutien à la zone euro de 500 à 1000 850
milliards la planche à billets tourne à
plein régime pour permettre aux états
plombés par la clé zuco vide de financer
leur quoi qu'il en coûte mais quelles
sont les limites à de cette politique
ultra généreuse est insuffisamment
ciblées on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques bonsoir stéphanie alors que
faut-il penser des décisions récemment
annoncées par la bce
oui effectivement la banque centrale
européenne a décidé la semaine dernière
de toute une série de mesures
ce sont des décisions qui sont
effectivement très importante parce que
si le plan de soutien à l'économie
décidé par la commission européenne va
mettre maintenant beaucoup de temps à
rentrer en action
on attend rien d'ici l'été prochain
et bien pour l'instant c'est
essentiellement la banque centrale
européenne qui fait le travail et c'est
un point qui est extrêmement important
en fait la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est est-ce que ces actions sont
susceptibles de pouvoir réellement
enrayer la crise économique alors
jacques à vous nourrit donc l'action de
la bce est bien plus importante en fait
que le plan de relance européen 750
milliards annoncés cet été
oui tout à fait tout à fait et là il
faut savoir que les différents pays
européens
il avait le choix effectivement entre
des mesures qui seraient des mesures
budgétaires et des mesures monétaires et
en fait ils ont donné la priorité aux
mesures monétaires alors ces mesures
monétaires c'est quoi ça c'est des
garanties de prêts cds crédit bonifié
ses différents types de crédits spéciaux
au total ces mesures monétaires
elle représente en allemagne et en
italie 30 % du pib je dis bien
% 15 % en france dès % en espagne en
particulier et on voit que par rapport à
ça et bien les dépenses budgétaires
restent nettement inférieurs alors
jacques est ce à dire que la bce a
largement ouvert le robinet du crédit
pour les états et pour les banques
oui vous savez de toute manière ça fait
déjà plusieurs années depuis que
monsieur draghi avait parlé de son
fameux bazooka monétaire déjà plusieurs
années que la bce avait une politique
que l'on peut considérer comme laxiste
elle avait d'ailleurs cherché à réduire
ses émissions au deuxième semestre de
2010 9
or là évidemment avec la pandémie de
l'aco vide 19
c'est reparti de manière spectaculaire
on le voit la masse monétaire s'accroît
d'un trimestre sur l'autre trimestre de
l'année précédente sur le même trimestre
de l'année précédente
s'accroît grosso modo de 6 à 7% jusqu'à
pratiquement 8 % et puis surtout on voit
que les crédits aux états et bien il
augmente de manière considérable ils ont
atteint pour le troisième trimestre de
2020 un accroissement de 6 % et quels
sont les instruments qu'elle utilise
alors le premier instrument
c'est ce que l'on appelle dans le jargon
de la bce
le ppp ou le punch bleus
le pandémique purchasing and see
programme c'est un programme de rachat
dead de rachat de titres qui est
spécifique à la pandémie
et c'est justement là où il ya quelque
chose d'important qui s'est passé on a
glissé si vous voulez de 13 150
milliards à 1850 milliards il ya grosso
modo une semaine jeudi dernier
bon c'est important parce qu'il faut
quand même dire que 1850 milliards de
rachats de titres
c'est l'équivalent pratiquement de 80%
du pib de la france et c'est
effectivement pour l'instant l'un des
principaux instruments de soutien à
l'économie dont s'est dotée la banque
centrale européenne alors jacques on dit
toujours qu'une banque centrale
intervient sur les taux d'intérêt oui
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
et c'est d'ailleurs l'instrument
absolument classique alors il faut
toujours rappeler que normalement la
banque centrale européenne l ajustement
à un objectif d'inflation ou disons une
limite d'inflation de l'ordre de 2%
or justement du fait de la pandémie
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
une situation qui est largement
déflationniste en fait l'inflation est
largement inférieure à 2% alors qu'est
ce que fait la banque centrale
européenne elle a un taux directeur qui
est à 0%
les autres taux ou qui sont des taux qui
sont des taux sur des périodes plus
courtes
ils sont même négatif entre -0 50 et 0
25%
néanmoins on voit bien qu'elle ne va pas
pouvoir aller très loin dans cette
direction si vous voulez un taux négatif
à - 2 - 3 % n'est tout simplement pas
possible parce que ça coûterait cher
justement à la bce et donc on voit une
chose c'est que autant l'action par les
taux elle est efficace quand il s'agit
de calmer l'inflation
mais face à la face à la déflation et
bien la banque centrale européenne elle
est relativement démunie et quels sont
donc les autres non pardon à qui
profites pardon mon cher jacques sait
politique de la bce alors bien tout
d'abord elle profite évidemment aux
états qui justement profitent de ces
rachats et de ses taux extrêmement
faible pour pouvoir se refinancer
avec un coût très faible elle devrait
aussi profiter aux banques si vous
voulez parce qu on voit très bien que
les banques vont être face à un risque
de crédits non performants ou en fait
d'impayés sur les sur les crédits qui va
être extrêmement important en 2021 et en
donc normalement ça devrait profiter
essentiellement aux banques
or ce que l'on constate et ça c'est un
point extrêmement intéressant c'est que
il n'y a que 25 % des sommes qui ont été
engagés par la bce qui sont allés aux
banques de la zone euro
alors quelles sont les autres
bénéficiaires mais justement c'est là
l'un des problèmes qui se posent on
constate quand on regarde ce qui se
passe sur les marchés
on constate que les 75% restants sont
allés à des sociétés financières non
bancaires et surtout des sociétés
financières qui ne se font pas partie de
la zone euro alors peut-être des
sociétés financières britanniques mais
ça peut être aussi des sociétés
financières américaines
qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien ça
veut dire que une grande partie de
l'argent que la banque centrale
européenne a mis sur le marché pour
aider l'économie européenne ne va pas
justement atteindre ses objectifs et va
plutôt partir en fond spéculatif et va
donc être un risque potentiel
d'instabilité dans les marchés
financiers dans les mois voire les
années à venir alors mais pourquoi les
banques ne bénéficie tels que de 25% de
rachat décidée par la bce dans ce cas ça
c'est effectivement l'une des lignes des
grandes questions
tous les ans on peut déjà dire une chose
c'est que la banque centrale européenne
eh bien elle doit d'une certaine air
s'occuper de tous les pays de la zone
euro c'est tout à fait
évident c'est tout à fait normal bon
mais ces pays ont eux mêmes des
situations qui sont extrêmement
divergents
ce qui fait que au lieu de pouvoir avoir
une politique monétaire ciblée comme
aurait une banque centrale nationale
comme a par exemple la banque centrale
du royaume uni la la bank of england
bon au lieu d'avoir ce type de politique
ciblée et bien la bce a une politique
d'arrosage générale sur les marchés et
donc il se fait que une grosse partie de
cet argent ne va pas là où ils devraient
aller autrement dit est bien la bce a
peut-être un swing comme on dit en
tennis qui est très puissant mais il ya
beaucoup de trous dans la raquette
donc en conclusion jacques vous vite que
l'action de la bce qui est la seule à
véritablement agi en réalité est en
partie inefficaces voire contre
productive
oui tout à fait tout avait si vous je ne
critique pas le fait que la bce agissent
parce que il faut toujours rappeler
elle est la seule à agir dans l'instant
puisque on voit bien que les actions de
soutien budgétaires de la commission
européenne donc de l'europe
eh bien nous commencerons à les voir se
matérialiser qu'à l'été prochain il faut
bien faire quelque chose d'ici là et de
fait la bce est la seule qui soit
capable de le faire mais en même temps
et on voit bien que la bce parce qu'elle
est justement cette banque de l'ensemble
de la zone euro parce qu'elle n'est pas
une banque qui connaissent bien
un pays eh bien elle n'arrive pas à
cibler effectivement une partie de ses
actions dont une partie de l'argent qui
va partir ailleurs qui va partir dans
des sociétés financières qui sont hors
zone euro est d'une certaine manière ce
type de politique ça fait courir un
risque de déstabilisation des marchés
non pas dans l'immédiat évidemment mais
pour l'année prochaine ou dans les deux
ans à venir et bien jacques merci pour
cet éclairage qui en dit long sur les
conséquences un financière à venir de
cette idée est la semaine prochaine coup
de sang des eurodéputés contre les
sanctions américaines imposées sur les
entreprises européennes en cas de
commerce avec à des pays autres que les
états-unis et veulent punir les
eurodéputés ont plaidé contre des
sanctions qui en freine sensiblement la
souveraineté territoriale des états
membres le cas de l'iran est
représentatif
après le retrait en 2018 des états unis
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
les entreprises européennes ont dû
cesser de vendre leurs produits à minuit
avoir accès au marché américain
le parlement européen entend désormais
une réaction de la commission
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
raphaël gauvin député la république en
marche cinquième série
saône-et-loire bonsoir raphaël gauvin
merci d'être avec nous alors des années
que ça dure finalement cette situation
pourquoi les eurodéputés montils au
créneau maintenant on va tout simplement
parce que ça ça a commencé en fait il ya
une dizaine d'années maintenant après la
crise financière de 2008 où les
américains au fait de plus en plus appel
à ses lois extraterritoriales donc la
lois extraterritoriales c'est là là
c'est une force de projection sceller
les américains imposent leur loi à
l'ensemble du monde l'exemple que vous
avez donnée de l'iran et est tout à fait
révélateur c'est à dire que du jour au
lendemain
l'administration américaine décide que
l'ensemble des entreprises dans le monde
entier et notamment les entreprises
européennes n'ont plus le droit de
commercer avec l'iran et donc les
entreprises européennes se retrouvent un
peu entre le marteau et l'enclume
d'un côté leurs droits propres elles ont
la possibilité de commercer avec l'iran
mais les américains les en empêche
avec des sanctions à la clé qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement importante et
récemment il ya eu d'autres menacés ce
qui explique sans doute la mobilisation
des européens avec les menaces de
sanctions sur vous les montrer dans le
reportage sur north stream de north
stream 2 c'est le pape lane le projette
'pipeline' entre la russie et
l'allemagne où là les américains et que
ce soit d'ailleurs côté démocrates comme
républicains
je pense qu'on va peut-être en reparler
mais l'arrivée de l'administration byden
enfin il faut pas que les européens
pensent que parce que là il va ya voir
arriver des démocrates
les sanctions et cette force de
projection
l'utilisation du droit comme une arme
dans la guerre économique va va
s'arrêter et d'ailleurs là là là là là
où les lois extraterritoriales ont pris
leur ampleur et là où il ya eu les les
plus fortes sanctions contre les
entreprises européennes je pense
notamment à bnp paribas en 2015 10
milliards de dollars
la banque française a été condamné sur
le fondement des lois extraterritoriales
par les américains
à 10 milliards de dollars ils s'étaient
sous l'administration obama donc il faut
une séquence pardonnez-moi des
conséquences très très lourde sur les
finances de ces entreprises européennes
et françaises
et pourtant une réciproque il n'est pas
vrai on est trop tendre en europe
justement avec les états unis on ne sait
pas assez défendu donc c'est pas assez
défendu c'est à dire que on a en a une
volonté 1 il ya une une volonté
politique notamment qui est affichée par
le président macro de rétablir cette
cette souveraineté française européenne
c'est cette politique d'indépendance ce
qu'a affiché aujourd'hui le parlement
européen va exactement dans cette ligne
mais là maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est
que on met en place des outils au
service de cette politique
d'indépendance et donc il faut que ça ce
que deux dans le cadre national
il faut qu'on prenne des mesures aussi
au parlement français mais surtout il
faut que entre européens ont su nice
plus et on met en place ces outils pour
lutter de manière défensive pour mieux
produire bien donnez moi bien sûr c'est
une intention de beaucoup de d'european
français ont mais regardez l'expérience
française des gaffes à bruno le maire a
qui essaient de faire tout même bouger
les choses à ce niveau là et c c'est
très compliqué souvent au niveau
européen on a du mal à se coordonner
extrêmement compliqué mais les choses
avancent
c'est un premier pas les choses avancent
mais bien sûr c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que les européens sont
souvent divisés et notamment les
américains utilisent nos divisions
contre ça et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
que bah il faut il faut continuer à
avancer il faut s'unir et mettre en
place mettre en place et je vais vous
donner un exemple en 1998 était bas sous
l'administration
c'était de l'administration clinton qui
avait mis en place des nouvelles
sanctions là c'était pas l'iran c'était
pas la russie et cuba et à cette époque
les leaks d'europe 1 a été uni les
européens étaient unis et avait mis en
place le règlement de 1998 qui était une
réponse jeu
dick à ces sanctions extraterritoriale
et bien à l'époque les américains
avaient reculé donc vaut absolument unis
aujourd'hui on a du mal de plus en plus
à s'unir pardon comment vous expliquer
qu'on est de plus en plus de mal
justement à s'unir qui est autant de
dissensions au niveau européen à ce que
les temps ont changé depuis la date que
vous même vous citez oui non pas tout
simplement parce qu'on sait que par
exemple en allemagne l'allemagne avait
très très peur des sanctions contre son
industrie automobile et donc été
extrêmement réticente à s'unir avec les
français pour lutter faire face et peser
contre les américains c'était aussi la
même chose avec les anglais qui avait
une tradition beaucoup plus atlantiste
exclamé les choses chance les choses
avancent et notamment ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui au parlement au parlement
européen
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
chose en tout cas il ya cette volonté
politique une nouvelle volonté politique
au niveau européen
et maintenant il faut faire un pas de
plus avancées et mettre en place que je
vous dise et ses outils au niveau
français comme européen
merci beaucoup avait fait le bon vin
gauvin députés la reine 5e
circonscription de saône-et-loire merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rtl
et retour en france pour finir cette
édition à rosny sous bois 23 habitations
sont promises à la démolition à cause du
tracé du nouveau métro de la ligne 15
les riverains sont dont on peu consterné
qui me sont été avertis bien après la
décision
un reportage signé quatre siècles
technique à rosny sous bois on peut
découvrir des surprises telles que ces
petits pavillons de banlieue havre de
paix niché entre les aux immeubles
malheureusement il est prévu que ces
maisons de la rue philibert hoffmann
soient toutes détruites
en cause les travaux du tronçon est de
la ligne 15 du projet du grand paris
l'ouvragé déclaré d'utilité publique les
23 habitations concernées dans
lesquelles vivent en majorité des
personnes âgées l'on a pris brutalement
par une lettre envoyée par la société du
grand paris
la sgp le riverain jean françois boulay
est catastrophé on a reçu une lettre
ordinaire même pas recommandé voilà donc
cette lettre a dit qu' on a besoin de
vos terrains et nous on est rentré dans
la maison en 99-2000 quoi juste à ce
moment là voilà donc ça fait un peu plus
de vingt ans que nous sommes là et on
était une journée venu là pour pouvoir
être tranquille pour la fin de nos jours
à partir de vendredi bah écoutez
monsieur vous partez vous imaginez quand
même le choc que ça représente et la
déception bien sûr jean françois boulay
a organisé une pétition et fédère les
habitants sous le choc j'ai croisé des
gens son trottoir moi je revenais de
chercher mon pain qui avait la lettre à
la main et il pleurait une personne de
80 ans pleurer en disant de l'aneth
c'est les gens qui vivent dans leur
pavillon contre souvenirs qui ont leurs
habitudes qu'on leur leur patrimoine
affectif et tout ça et on leur dit vous
partiez en plus on vous rajoute ou moi
j'espère avoir la force de négocier à
vous il ya peu près comment mais il ya
des gens contre 87 cents comment ils
vont négocier
il y a deux ans le tracé de devaient
menacer qu'une école mais des études
complémentaires ont estimé qu'un ouvrage
appelé antoine mans pouvait être réduit
de 200 m en passant par un nouveau
périmètre la société du grand paris a
choisi ce scénario avec l'accord de
l'ancien maire de rosny sous bois
mais les habitants n'ont pas été
informés nous avons pu consulter un
document d' usage interne de la sgp
il prend acte du fait que l'ancien maire
a demandé de ne pas initier de contact
avec les propriétaires avant avril 2020
soit avant les élections municipales
un secret qui révoltent l'adjoint au
maire pierre olive et karel mis devant
le fait accompli est un véritable
déchirement non seulement d'avoir appris
de manière assez incidente le nouveau
projet mais également l'impact humain
que ça va avoir sur les résidents qui
sont là depuis tant d'années et on a
découvert au détour d'un compte rendu de
réunion qui a eu lieu au mois de juillet
2019 que l'ancien maire avait demandé à
la société du grand paris de ne n'avoir
aucune communication avant le mois
d'avril 2020 à l'époque n'avait pas
encore la perspective du confinement
donc c'était post élections municipales
lui il ya la ligne 15 mois à côté de
chez moi j'ai la ligne 11 donc n'importe
qui peut être concerné et on voit bien
que c'est les plus humbles qui trinque à
chaque fois aujourd'hui jean françois
boulay se sent bien seul
j'écris là au grand paris pour demander
une explication ils ne répondent pas
j'ai écrit à banier elle ne répond pas
je suis tout seul
contactée la société du grand paris
explique que ce nouveau tracé permet de
diminuer les nuisances du chantier est
de réduire sa durée
elle explique connaître qu'au tout début
des négociations et que pour cette
raison un contact téléphonique n'a pas
encore été initié la sgp promet
d'organiser une réunion en janvier et
d'accompagner chaque propriétaire au cas
par cas
reste la détresse des habitants dont la
maison et la tranquillité vont
s'effondrer
et puis cette pause dans le conflit
social qui vise le site de general
electric à villeurbanne un accord vient
d'être signé aujourd'hui à paris par
trois syndicats dont la cgt il met fin à
il met fin à quatre semaines de grève
illimitée est il à saraf c'est quand on
est solide en effectue depuis mardi 15
employés du site degré de solution avant
ta mais une grève de la faim lui ouvrier
était encore dans l'infirmerie du site
jeudi matin avant un accord entre
syndicats et direction
à la mi-journée 80 postes ont été sauvés
sur les 285 suppression envisagée
nous l'argent n'en veut pas on veut du
travail pour pouvoir justement pouvoir
payer nos impôts payer nos factures
payer nos loyers et des lobbys sont nos
enfants
pouvoir se projeter familialement
personnellement investir dans l'avenir
de nos enfants c'est ça qu'on demande
nous on va partir comme des êtres
humains on a travaillé pour vous relater
week end au portugal en faute à nous
mais il faut plus de maîtrise dans le
cadre de l'accord les conditions de
départ ont également été revus et
améliorés
on est sur un plan quand même immense
impro villeurbanne 285 suppression sans
455 on a quand même réussi à la sauver
80 familles et on a aussi réussi à la
faire en sorte que les personnes qui
seront licenciées
on aura une base de négociation des
négociations convenable donc on va
partir avec des sommes qui restent quand
même insuffisant et qui sont nettement
meilleures qu'il ya quatre semaines les
ouvriers qui étaient en grève totale
depuis le 23 novembre restent néanmoins
sur leurs gardes
prêt à d'autres négociations à partir de
la rentrée on va pas lâcher le morceau
qu'on va repartir de l'avant et on va
vraiment essayer de paul du paquebot
tout cas c'est vraiment s'il faut pas
s'arrêter là mais vraiment va pas
s'arrêter là
ou alors c'est une belle victoire mais
on n'a pas gagné la guerre la guerre on
va tout faire pour aider outre la
défense des emplois à les syndicats
redoutent également la perte de
compétences stratégiques du pays
le site industriel est un site
d'expertisé en matière de disjoncteur
haute tension depuis 1916 restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la grand messe annuelle
de vladimir poutine qui a répondu
pendant plus de quatre heures aux
questions des journalistes le président
russe qui souhaite un beau prêteront
pompe d'un rétablissement à son
homologue français manuel mecs ont testé
positif au co bide
nombre de dirigeants européens et des
membres du gouvernement se passe comme
lui à l'isolément
[Musique]
non
oui
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tronches et
pour reprendre un code policiers il vous
a reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé leur matin est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radical à
sion mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté la liberté d'expression et
d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la densité brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population un territoire qui est porteur
de causalité une explication mais des
densités un train si je vis en
appartement
il ya des chaînes de contagion dit zoto
à l'intérieur rassemblement milieu
familial parce qu on a des familles qui
vivre à trois générations et c'est tout
cet ensemble de causes qui
constitutionnellement un syndrome en
quelque sorte social et dont le
gaullisme est à la fois le révélateur
est malheureusement la cause
déterminante ponctuelles suis très
frappé en rente représentants des
sciences sociales par finalement le
progrès considérables comme à fait dans
cette endémie la mondialisation a pas
que des mauvais côtés en un an on a mis
au point pratiquement aveugle
[Musique]
il parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder
poutre et pays occidentaux ont favorisé
cette dérive en encourageant le maintien
au pouvoir de politiciens de plus en
plus âgés pour assurer la stabilité des
pays et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles où
s'esquissent les figures du monde à
venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en aux croyants co
management à l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors jean
funky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise non vraie
bêtise c'est à dire que vous dépendrez
entièrement de l'état le problème du
revenu et recel c'est effectivement il y
aura une contrepartie ce sera qu'on va
supprimer un certain nombre d' aide
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que
finalement les 9,2 millions de pauvres
on a dans ce pays vont être encore plus
beau c'est un espèce de nivellement par
le bas c'est à dire tout le monde à 750
euros mais avec 750 euros vous pouvez
vivre les entreprises on attendait juste
eu la peine de payer 2000 euros les gens
ils ont déjà 300 euros par mois
là on parle de 400 milliards pour faire
un revenu universel et 400 milliards 70%
ont pib on fait comment on les sort d'où
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma
enlève les yeux tout est dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mieux 21h heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 17
décembre plus de quatre heures de
questions réponses lors de la grand
messe annuelle de vladimir poutine face
à la presse le président russe qui est
abordé par visioconférence de nombreux
sujets internationaux comme la future
relation washington moscou
la crise sanitaire est également au
coeur des échanges le chef du kremlin se
fera vacciner contre le coronavirus dès
que ce sera possible pour que sa
catégorie d'âge
la russie devrait disposer d'ici l'année
prochaine deux millions de doses de
vaccins
emmanuel m qu'on lui ait testé positif
aux commis 19 il annuler son déplacement
au liban de mardi et son réveillant avec
les militaires de la finul agenda
présidentiel bouleversé en même temps
que celui de nombreux politiques
français
et chefs d'état étrangers considérés
comme cas contacts et contre un
isolement
l'opposition n'a pas manqué de lui
souhaiter un prompt rétablissement mais
aussi d'ironiser largement sur
d'éventuels manquements aux gestes
barrières pourtant imposée aux français
les etats-unis confrontés depuis plus
d'un mois un spectaculaire rebond de
l'épidémie c'est la troisième fois que
le pays franchir la barre des 3000 morts
quotidiens en une semaine
vieux continent aussi fait face à la
deuxième vague plusieurs pays renforcent
leurs restrictions sanitaires
al'approche défaite et se prépare à
vacciner les populations prioritaires
agence européenne des médicaments avance
aussi janvier cette décision sur le
vaccin moderna cette fois
[Musique]
c'était il ya dix ans joueront jour un
vendeur ambulant s'est immolé par le feu
à sidi bouzid en tunisie pour dénoncer
ses conditions de vie un drame qui
marquait le début du printemps arabe et
qui conduisit au départ du pouvoir du
président ben ali
nous verrons ce qui reste aujourd'hui de
ce soulèvement qui suscitait alors un
grand espoir dans le pays
[Musique]
le dhimmi routine a donc répondu pendant
plus de quatre heures aux questions des
médias exercice que le président russe
affectionne particulièrement
une prise de parole par visioconférence
crise sanitaire oblige les précisions de
notre reporter antoine l'hérault à
moscou l'exercice aura duré cette année
4h30 une conférence de presse lors de
laquelle de très nombreux sujets ont été
évoqués avec en premier lieu bien
entendu cette pandémie de kobe 19
il était question du système de santé
russes et sa capacité à s'adapter de
l'impact de cette crise sanitaire sur
l'économie ou encore des vaccins
développés par la russie ce propos un
journaliste a même posé la question
suivante à vladmir poutine
monsieur le président allez-vous vous
faire vacciner les vaccins qui sont en
circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge est pour
l'instant gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie jeu
mais je respecte la loi je suis les
recommandations de nos spécialistes est
pour l'instant moi je me suis fais pas
je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je le
ferai dès que ce sera possible
il a largement été question du coc vide
vladimir poutine a au passage souhaité
un prompt rétablissement à emmanuel
macron en marge de cette conférence de
presse mais de nombreux thèmes de
l'actualité internationale ont aussi été
abordés on peut citer par exemple les
situations dans le haut-karabagh en
ukraine ou encore en biélorussie
vladimir poutine a également dit vouloir
améliorer les relations entre la russie
et les etats unis avec l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche notamment via
le renouvellement du traité new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques
la ferme la vanille a elle aussi été
évoquée avec les dernières accusations
de médias occidentaux qui mettent en
cause des agents du fsb
écoutez je dirais que je patients de la
clinique
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
synthes endroit ça veut dire
qu'effectivement les services secrets
doivent suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors l'enquêté peut-être
un peu peut-être pas achevé il faut la
poursuivre son épouse a demandé à
pouvoir le suivre en allemagne j'ai
donné l'autorisation
enfin interrogé sur les chefs d'état
étrangers avec qui ils apprécient
négocier et échanger le président russe
a donné de nom le dirigeant chinois xi
jinping avec qui il dit entretenir une
relation d'amitié et le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan
chez qu'il apprécie le franc parler est
vrai que les deux hommes s'opposent sur
de nombreux dossiers mais arrive
toujours à communiquer à s'entendre de
façon concrète
c'est ainsi que s'est terminée cette
conférence de presse au format
inhabituel certes mais qui aura permis à
vladimir poutine de s'exprimer sur de
très nombreux sujets le président
français testés positifs au co vite 19
filets pc 7 jours à l'isolément
dans son sillage de nombreux hommes
politiques français et chefs d'état
étrangers qu'à contacter l agenda
présidentiel et donc bouleversé pour la
semaine à venir puisque emmanuel m
caumont macron se rendre à ne se rendra
pas au liban mardi ne réveillera donc
pas avec elle et militaires français de
la finul à beyrouth
ouahbi de béthanie une proximité évident
emmanuel macron proches ces dernières
heures de son premier ministre jean
castex considéré de fait comme qu'à
contacter ce dernier placé à l'isolément
pour sept jours avant d'être testé
négatif ce jeudi et vie professionnelle
vie de famille brigitte macron ne
présente pour l'heure aucun symptôme
après avoir été testées négatives mardi
lundi emmanuel macron s'est ouvert à
l'europe avec un déjeuner en compagnie
de la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen
le secrétaire général de l' ocde angel
gurria
le président du conseil européen charles
michel et le premier ministre espagnol
pedro sanchez
ces deux derniers se sont placés ali
seulement le premier ministre espagnol
testé d'ailleurs négatif elle lundi
toujours la direction la planète rugby à
2,7 km de l'elysée le palais brongniart
et le tirage au sort de la coupe du
monde 2023 compétition qui accueilleront
les stars françaises du ballon ovale
présent lundi au côté du chef de l'état
tout comme le président de la fédération
française de rugby bernard laporte lundi
soir emmanuel macron s'est rendu à dix
minutes de son domicile pour présider la
convention citoyenne pour le climat en
compagnie de cinq ans portant ministre
et d'olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
sans oublier une dizaine de citoyens
distanciation sociale et masques maîtres
mots de la rencontre mardi rime avec
pluralité et des jeunes et les
présidents de groupes parlementaires ps
agir ensemble
elle est répartie communiste français
aux côtés de richard ferrand mais les
dernières 24 heures reste peut-être les
plus compliquées avec le traditionnel
conseil des ministres le porte parole du
gouvernement
gabriella talent présent aussi dans la
journée emmanuel macron à des jeunes et
également avec le premier ministre
portugais antonio costa marcredi soir à
dîner à l'elysée avec les principaux
responsables de la majorité comme le
président de l'assemblée nationale le
patron de la république en marche
le chef député lrm et françois bayrou
ainsi que plusieurs conseillers à noter
enfin qu emmanuel macron il y a une
semaine se rendait à bruxelles pour un
conseil européen et d'intenses
négociations alors qu'en pensent les
français et mende réponse avec un ces
témoignages que nous avons recueillis
dans les rues de paris en tant que chef
de l'état il devrait donner l'exemple
aussi donc à tous les français et
respecter lui-même les recommandations
qui il est qui donne aux français donc
voilà ce serait bien qu'ils testent
son fameux vaccin pour qu'ils puissent
donner l'exemple aussi à tous les
français donc voilà pour moi le port du
miz du masque et le confinement le
couvre feu c'est vraiment des lois qui
devraient pas être impliquées comme ça
et
et au final il ne les respectent même
pas donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
choquant je trouve un président a
probablement des responsabilités que le
français moyen n'a pas donc j'imagine
que oui ils étaient obligés de se réunir
avec ces gens là nous on n'a pas le
droit d'être plus de 6 à noël mais lui
il a le droit d'être à 11 la fin de
longues qui veut et s'achète personnes
face à chaque pas lui du coup du moins
il nous dit à nous de ne pas de passes
assemblée mais lui-même signé respecte
pas ses propres dires quoi ça reste un
peu d'hypocrisie envers le peuple
français qui lui se prive depuis déjà
longtemps et lui se permet de faire un
peu ce qu'il veut quoi le président
testés positifs au co vide qui s'isole
une kyrielle de dirigeants d'icc à
contacter dans son sillage alors quel
impact sur la présidence quelle question
justement sur l'exemplarité au sommet de
l'état le chef de l'état at il respecté
toutes les mesures sanitaires qui sent
qu'il impose pourtant aux français place
à notre décryptage avec notre invité
[Musique]
prix pour en parler nous sommes avec
alain brunel députée pcf 16e
circonscription du nord bonsoir alain
bruneel merci d'être avec nous jérôme
bascher sénateurs et l'air de l'oise
bonsoir à vous également jérôme bascher
merci d'être avec nous alors un dîner
avec les chefs de groupe à l'assemblée
un déjeuner hier midi avec une dizaine
de personnes un conseil des ministres
par dessus le tout alors que le
gouvernement nous recommande depuis des
semaines de ne pas être plus de 6 à
table et de respecter les gestes
barrière est ce qu'on peut dire que le
président n'a pas montré l'exemple
alain bruneel comme à l'air de le penser
ces quelques français en tout cas on a
entendu sur cette antenne moi je pense
j'ai pas fait parce que l'on vit une
situation depuis de mad max avec des
confinement des recommandations quand ça
va pas on dit que c'est les français qui
font très bien qu'ils ne mettent pas les
gestes barrières et puis là on apprend
que le prénom la république lui ne
respecte pas du tout les gestes barrière
c'est ça qui est dramatique parce qu'il
ya plus de confiance entre les citoyens
et le présente dans le public c'est une
grave question
alors je voudrais simplement dire vrai
on a un public dont je souhaite un bon
rétablissement ainsi que tous ceux et
toutes celles qui sont aujourd'hui un
tas de la copie de 19 mais je voudrais
dire aussi au président que lorsqu'il
parle de virus qui circule un peu
partout et qu'il faut faire attention et
qui nous donne sur recommandations ainsi
qu'ensemble des ministres eh ben je me
sers ne manque que le virus lui il
s'invite partout quelle que soit la
situation sociale des citoyens mais y
compris à l'interdît alors effectivement
depuis que l'information a été
communiqué à la mi journée un beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup de pensées
comme la vôtre alain bruneel et beaucoup
de railleries aussi et regardez par
exemple tweet d'eric coquerel député la
france insoumise en seine-saint-denis
brunch tragique à l'elysée le sommet de
l'état en isolement mais que fait la
police
annie responsable porteur du coc vide
apprend t-on organise un déjeuner de
plus de 10 personnes sur invitation
contraintes et pourtant sans protection
barrière rue du faubourg saint-honoré
autre réaction celle du député les
républicains d'eure et loir olivier
marc l'ex une pensée pour tous les
restaurateurs de france acquis emmanuel
macron interdit de travailler dix
personnes à dîner à l'elysée alors
jérôme bascher c'est vrai que voilà on
l'a entendu avec ces français on
l'entend par ses réactions de
responsables politiques d'élus il ya un
côté voilà on nous demande de faire des
sacrifices et lui ne le fait pas et ce
qu'il serait d'une certaine manière au
dessus des lois est ce que c'est votre
opinion également en tout cas vous vous
interrogez en ce sens ça devant par
exemple et on reconnaît un député vient
de l'exprimer parfaitement lorsque vous
demandez à noël ne pas être plus de 6 à
table lorsque le premier ministe d'y
aller à tes amis pour aller chercher les
enfants à la sortie de l'école c'est pas
possible
lorsque vous voyez bien que toute la
crédibilité de la parole gouvernementale
présidentielle après que le sénat a eut
révélé que jérôme ça le lot avait menti
sur les masses ce que les français
s'avèrent mais howard le nom la personne
qui ment et qui manipule
vous voyez bien que la confiance
complète dans les puissances gouvernante
pour gérer ces épidémies est
catastrophique
je fais de moi comme mon collègue député
un bon rétablissement à tous ceux qui
sont atteints que vides je vive en
lisant la république soit symptomatique
mais le sale tour c'est celui de ne pas
respecter la parole et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète le plus
pour le président la relie être 10 adam
je le lis ces coûts balle c'est
aujourd'hui ou pas il faut parler des
leçons échec lyon il faut faire et elle
va le faire ça veut arriver à chacun
d'entre eux moi je sais que par exemple
à noël je serai sais pas ce que je vais
pas faire autrement mais c'est comme
cela on essayé de limiter au maximum et
où nous venons juste de marc ira
personnes on peut me donner l'exemple et
on peut
évitez ces idées travail de fin de
période qui sont les heureux en fait le
président le gouvernement pourrait nous
répondre voilà on travaille pour l'état
pour les français c'est peut-être
différent de faire un repas de noël
ah c'est ça qu'est ce que vous pourriez
répondre la différence quand on donne
des conseils aux citoyens et que leur
demande d'être responsables et prudents
et qu'on lui ont alors dit écoutez les
fêtes de noël le couvre-feu ma nouvelle
enfin quand on sait très bien que
défaite c'est important c'est très bien
que vous avez besoin de vous retrouver
en fin d'année c'est normal c'est la
famille
mais en même temps on vous dit soyez pas
plus que 6 1 mais on ne peut pas les
enfants genre pas et disent c'est pas
normal on peut pas accepter ça et moi je
suis d'accord avec eux ce qui était
pisté twitté pardon tout à l'heure c'est
de dire pourquoi on demande aux français
de faire ça aux restaurateurs de fermer
à la culture de le palais sourire mais
c'est incompréhensible ça on peut pas
peut pas diriger le pays de cette
manière là et après on va dire aux gens
car dès aujourd'hui à plus de 18000 cas
qui vient de renforcer et on dit faut
atteindre 5000 personnes mais pourquoi
on atteint 5000 d'abord c'est parce que
hier pas sévi dans l'animation
c'est pour ça qu'on va atteindre 5000 et
qu'est ce qu'on a donné comme moyen
d'hôpitaux est-ce qu'on a ouvert comme
l'y rien du tout et ça continue comme si
rien n'était et nous on a droit
enfin et que le prénom encore dix ans
après je suppose l'autre ce qui va
réapparaître des visons disons voilà
j'ai pas fait attention
est-ce qu'il va s'excuser auprès des
français c'est irresponsable moi j'ai
dit franchement s'est dit responsable
d'un gouvernement et d'un président la
république de dire aux gens vous devez
faire est lui-même ne pas respecter les
consignes de l'ariège center alors
conséquences en cascade évidemment pour
l'exécutif jean castex testés négatifs
mais qui est quand même à l'isolément
par précaution ils auront également pour
le président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand richard perron qui a
fait beaucoup parler de lui aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a enfoncé le clou écouter
ses propos qui datent de fin octobre
dernier il ne suffit pas d'avoir peur
il faut aussi faire attention si nous
sommes malades demain c'est qu'à un
moment donné nous n'aurons pas fait
aussi attention que nécessaire chacun
d'entre nous doit être en vie
lens pour les autres et pour soi même
c'est quand on se relâche qu'on laisse
ce virus nous attaquer ce n'est pas une
question de faute
c'est une question de responsabilité
alors voici pour les propos de richard
ferrand vous pensez que richard ferrand
appelé manuel de macron pour lui dès
qu'il n'avait pas fait attention que
c'était un petit peu relâché jérôme
bascher au jeu c'est bon il peut arriver
à tout le monde et pour que les luttes
de pouvoir entre nous entre énormément
énormément et dans des positions variées
et lui comme moi prenons les transports
en commun je suppose que comme il prend
le train pour venir à paris
et il ya les bons défi à l'égard du nord
je vais aussi garder nord et laurent le
1er mai 1 à 6 8 euros et on raconte
beaucoup de gens dont nous a semblé
exclure à ce toute la journée moi j'ai
lu voir des mers n'était pas ce qu'il
était à distance dans les pièces à y
rester mais enfin il faut rencontrer les
gens ne peut pas de pavés dont les
gestes barrières ils sont nécessaires
pour éviter une peau une progression
trop rapide mais ça n'empêche à tout ça
n'empêche pas tout donc le plaisir d'un
public bien normalement un voix détendre
de personnes dans ses fonctions et le
monde continue à vivre et à la vivre
tant qu'ils essaient diakiss en recul
mais c'est vrai que la révélation de ce
dîner et fait vraiment tâche au moment
où tous les françaises vivent
moi j'aurais nous dire ça fait plusieurs
mois que les reçus personnes archers sur
moi a pas mes parents qui habitent à
côté personnes tories à un moment
j'étais vais pas me plaindre
il ya des gens très isolée de forêt qui
font fort et des personnes malades et on
n'a pas le droit de recevoir nous l'a
dit on essaye de faire les efforts et
vous voyez bien que le président de la
république qui a demandé les efforts aux
français les a félicité tous les quinze
jours à la télévision pour leurs efforts
et bien lui dit - jeu reasoner non non
là il ya un vrai problème vous pouvez
pas faire confiance avec quelqu'un qui
me demande sans arrêt à faire des
efforts comme un vecteur en collègues
députés aux sportifs
aux artistes présents à tout le monde et
puis vous de vous exonérer cet effort il
vient s'exonérer d'efforts page ans tout
de suite ils vous avez dans le mode est
à vous faire très attention et je ne
sais pas si je suis moi-même exempt de
tout reproche et donc faisons bien
attention les uns les autres
alain bruneel selon vous est ce qu'il y
aura un impact politique sur les
présidentes des manuels micron parce que
c'est vrai que finalement ce n'est pas
le seul un dirigeant on les signes
depuis la mi-journée donald trump
boris johnson johnson araud c'est pas le
seul à avoir attrapé le coronavirus
emmanuel macron il y aura des
conséquences selon vous en france je
sais pas s'il ya des conséquences tout
ce que je peux affirmer c'est que la
confiance n'y est plus entre les
citoyens et le gouvernement
après c'est des citoyens qui décideront
s'il ya des conséquences sur la
politique du président de la république
et puis de ce gouvernement
par contre là il montre pas l'exemple et
c'est ça qui est important c'est que
lorsqu'on est président lorsqu'on est
responsable on collègues il l'a dit à
quelques instants on a effectivement
rencontre des gens dans des réunions on
tient nos distances
on n'est pas à l'abri ça c'est clair
mais on fait extrêmement attention
moi je pense aussi que nous on fait
attention et aussi les citoyens font
extrêmement intentions les citoyens sont
des gens intelligents il ya une force
extraordinaire à travers les citoyens à
prétendants dirait des testeurs par six
les quotas mais la majorité
après ça pose quand même la question est
ce qu'on est sur le bon chemin
au niveau du de la cobi 19 parce que
l'on va voir les vaccins qui m'arrive
est la plus d'un million ici avant la
fin de l'année une première première
phase mais est ce que c'est le bon moyen
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire comme
d'autres pays confiné pendant quelques
semaines pour éviter que le virus
circule et faire le choix de sauver des
vies au lieu que le ici de faire le
choix de sauver l'économie
jérôme bascher ça pose aussi évidemment
la question de la sacralisation de la
fonction on ne compte plus les
présidents de la république français qui
ont caché leurs pépins de santé du plus
grave au plus bénins d'ailleurs est ce
que vous laissez au moins vous concédez
au moins emmanuel macron qui
une forme de transparence sur sur cet
épisode aujourd'hui tous ceux qui sur
les réseaux par le complot sur le
coville et ses trois aires ça va
permettre de tuer ses idées au moins je
l'espère que tous les complotistes en
tous genres pense que c'est à un faux
seins faux sujet ce virus
bon voilà président et lui qui est
touchée comme n'importe quel humain il
est touchant et ce n'est pas intouchable
il est trop sévèrement je l'espère pour
lui parce que c'est quand même bien dans
les internats spécialité honda le jeu
rappelle leur nucléaire que le président
de la république je rêve à peu près dans
un état de santé et de capacité le plus
total bon et ce qui va avoir et ça lui
peu importe ce que je veux dire c'est
que d'importer qui peuvent le toucher et
que tout le monde doit faire attention
et on a 30 ans et c'est normal que
différence père chez les gaullistes et
les communistes sur ça sera au chai
euros il faut résister ensemble mais sur
l'économie ça aussi importante at il dit
et c'est vrai que j'ai constaté ces
derniers jours à paris que dans les
magasins par exemple il y avait des
foulées incroyable et il ne faudra pas
s'étonner qu'il y ait troisième bague je
le dis vraiment simplement ce n'est pas
possible autrement
ce n'est pas possible autrement cela est
inquiétant créera d'autres soucis
d'autres d'autres épreuves
mais j'aimerais bien avoir un capitaine
du navire qui lui demande beaucoup
d'humilité qu'ils soient effectivement
exemplaires
vous venez de mettre le doigt sur sur le
problème aujourd'hui est ce que quand on
verra emmanuel macron nous parler de
guerre à la télévision nous dire de
faire des efforts parce que s'il ya une
troisième vague ça veut peut-être dire
qu'il y aura un nouveau confinement dans
ces conditions comment demander
justement aux français d'accepter un
nouveau confinement ce que ça voilà où
ça n'a rien à voir peut-être alain
bruneel après s'il ya une troisième
vague qui risque qui se dessine de toute
façon malheureusement on souhaite pas
qu'elle ait lieu mais tout le monde dit
qu'aujourd'hui on va sur la troisième
vague et que les fêtes de fin d'année
risque aussi d'entraîner la troisième il
va falloir prendre des décisions et
quand le président de la république par
exemple dans le cadre de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat propose un état
sanitaire rien état d'urgence sanitaire
nous votons nous votons donc chaîne car
il donne son avis là dessus donc moi je
vais pense que les citoyens sont
responsables alors que l'opposant à un
public qui disent après comment on va
faire sur la troisième balle et qui a
des dispositions qu'ils soient prises
effectivement elles seront prises
parce que les gens quand je parle
d'intelligence collecter des gens sont
des gens intelligents et savent très
bien qu'ils n'ont pas prendre de risque
mais aussi pour leurs familles ils sont
déjà aussi malheureux comme ça quand ça
se passe pour un mandant famille
lorsqu'ils peuvent pas non plus assisté
à un enterrement
lorsqu'ils peuvent pas être auprès de
leurs proches le colosse lui si
malheureux non décèle par le comité bon
je pense qu'après c'est le cas une
troisième vague les gens y vont ils vont
obliger de façon si un confinement sont
obligés de le suivre alors que soit le
président obama le président mais
président avec ce qui a dit le manque de
confiance aujourd'hui ce qui a été fait
également un pays touché par la cobi 19
atik certainement du gouvernement les
gens vont vont quand même écouter et
donc vont essayer aussi aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte qu' on puisse pas des
hôpitaux que le qui a - en cas moins
deux personnes touchées c'est un peu ça
donc confiance pas confiance les gens
m'ont fait automatiquement pour vous
basser non mais écoutez moi je suis
surtout que le sang soit efficace ce dos
et qu'il n'ait pas de conséquences
secondaires sévères des choses cassées
aussi dans l'histoire soit
d'entraînement fois damas a que résidera
le vrai espoir je ne crois plus beaucoup
aux solutions du gouvernement et voilà
aujourd'hui on a une crédibilité de ceux
qui nous dirigent
donc il faut essayer de recouvrer un peu
de croyance dans la science et de la
médecine
pour l'instant je comprends le
scepticisme des français moi je le dis
très sincèrement j'étais dans les tous
premiers vaccinés contre la grippe à la
fin de ma vie pour en écouter liés aux
gens là s'y dévouent compagnie pour
éviter d'avoir le double effet que vides
grippe
là j'avoue que je ne suis pas du tout
alors qu'il est prioritaire mais je
rembourse inquiètes des conséquences
secondaires forcément sur ce vaccin les
fruits espérés vraiment qui fonctionne
qu'on y arrive et qu'on aura pas la
fascination comme arrêter parce qu'on a
raté le testing quand arrêter le confine
ce soir emmanuel macron se confinera à
la long terme cette résidence des
présidents français proche de versailles
merci à vous deux alain bruneel et
jérôme bascher d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du robot de
l'épidémie aux etats-unis également mais
aussi en europe danemark allemagne
encore royaume-uni durcissent à nouveau
les restrictions à la poche des fêtes de
fin d'année et puis nous reviendrons sur
le printemps arabe c'était il ya dix ans
le 17 décembre 2010 le suicide d'un
vendeur ambulant de tunis déclencher une
vague de soulèvements dans le monde
arabe
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer que l'un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire rasé à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma
enlève les yeux de teddy
[Musique]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise non vraie
bêtise c'est à dire que vous dépendrez
entièrement de l'état le problème du
revenu et recel c'est effectivement il y
aura une contrepartie ce sera qu'on va
supprimer un certain nombre d' aide
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que
finalement les 9,2 millions de pauvres
on a dans ce pays vont être encore plus
beau c'est un espèce de nivellement par
le bas c'est à dire tout le monde à 750
euros mais avec 750 euros vous pouvez
vivre les entreprises on attendait juste
eu la peine de payer 2000 euros les gens
ils ont déjà 300 autres ont fait des
crises - là on parle de 400 milliards
pour faire un revenu universel et 400
milliards 70% ont pib on fait comment on
les sort d'où
[Musique]
on nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont plus la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles où
s'esquissent les figures du monde à
venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france en
europe plusieurs pays renforcent leurs
restrictions sanitaires et se prépare à
vacciner les populations prioritaires
berlin espère débuter sa campagne de
vaccination à partir du 27 décembre
en attendant l'allemagne renforcent ces
mesures tout comme le royaume uni ou le
danemark ont fait le point avec maxime
hébert londres ces pubs l'allemagne ses
magasins et le danemark ces écoles
al'approche défaite ces trois pays
européens renforcent leurs mesures face
au co vide 19 un choix qui fait suite
aux mauvais chiffres enregistrés ces
derniers jours en allemagne
la deuxième vague est beaucoup moins
maîtrisé que la première ce mercredi
berlin a enregistré un record de 17 952
en 24 heures les commerces jugés non
essentiels ont fermé jusqu'au 10 janvier
une mesure qui choque dans un pays où
les clients n'ont jamais trouvé portes
closes depuis la première vague au
printemps
je regardais tout à l'heure ça fait vide
disant que je pense que personne n'était
préparé à ça parce que c'est une
décision qui a été pris à la vite fait
et hier c'était encore le dernier jour
d'achat est tout bon on n'a pas le choix
donc on fait avec le royaume uni lui
ferme ses pubs mais aussi ses
restaurants et ses hôtels approche de
noël et ce pour la troisième fois depuis
le début de la pandémie
pourtant boris johnson ne souhaite pas
revenir sur l'autorisation donnée de se
déplacer entre le 23 et le 27 décembre
alors que se multiplient les appels pour
renoncer à ce relâchement
la situation générale et elle aspire est
plus difficile que ce que nous avions
espéré
lorsque nous avons établi les règles
ainsi même s'il ne serait pas juste
selon nous de criminaliser les personnes
qui ont fait des projets et qui veulent
simplement passer du temps avec leurs
proches
nous vous demandons collectivement à
travers le royaume uni les gouvernements
à tous les niveaux 2
réfléchir sérieusement et en détails aux
jours à venir et de voir si vous pouvez
faire plus pour vous protéger et
protéger les autres
au danemark enfin tous les commerces
seront fermés pendant les fêtes du 25
décembre au 3 janvier le pays sera
complètement fermée a déclaré la
première ministre danoise seule
exception les magasins d'alimentation et
les pharmacies ce sont nos propres
actions et choix qui déterminent la
manière dont le danemark traverse la
crise je voudrais demander à tous les
danois de montrer la même force et le
même sens de la communauté qui nous ont
permis de traverser le printemps les
mesures de semis confinement vigueur
comme la fermeture des collèges et
lycées ou des lieux culturels ont été
également étendu à l'ensemble du pays
al'approche des fêtes de fin d'année
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
recommandé mercredi le port du masque
lors des réunions familiales
mettant en garde contre un risque élevé
de reprise de l'épidémie début 2000 21
en europe alors même que les 27 pays de
l'ue devrait pouvoir commencer à
vacciner le même jour et avant la fin de
l'année contre le communisme et
l'espagne elle aussi à nouveau en alerte
à l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année si
la situation sanitaire s'améliorait
depuis plusieurs semaines et contagion
repartent elles aussi à la hausse à
madrid et à barcelone notamment et la
cause pourrait bien être un long
week-end férié au début du mois c'est
aux baléares et sont tous sur l'île de
majorque épargné jusque là que les
chiffres sont inquiétants avec plus de
400 cas pour 100000 habitants soit le
double de la moyenne du pays
en espagne également où le chef du
gouvernement pedro sanchez vers d'être
testés négatifs mais va s'isoler tout de
même jusqu'au 24 décembre car il était
lui aussi qu'à contacter d'emmanuel
macron pour en parler de l'espagne nous
sommes avec philippe emmanueli médecins
français exerçant à barcelone bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous une petite
question tout d'abord sur le chef du
gouvernement espagnol pedro sanchez qui
va s'isoler il est lui aussi qu'à
contacter d'emmanuel macron je ne sais
pas si vous avez eu l'occasion de
regarder les chaînes d'information
peut-être espagnol cet après midi
comment réagit-on en espagne ou en tout
cas comment réagit peut-être plus facile
pour vous d'y répondre le médecin que
vous êtes
voilà des chefs d'état des chefs du
gouvernement qui se met peut-être en
danger les uns et les autres ça vous
inspire quoi ils n'ont pas assez
respecté les mesures sanitaires qu'ils
imposent peut-être à leur peuple
bonsoir c'était fini de murs rue alors
évidemment c'est une question que je me
suis posée c'est à dire qu'elle est
qu'elle est effectivement le rôle du
chef de l'état en termes d'exemplarité
dans ce contexte et je crois que on ne
peut pas à la fois demander à un chef de
l'état d'assumer ses fonctions avec la
complexité de la charge dans une période
particulièrement difficile où
probablement la charge de travail qui
incombe au président de la république
est plus importante qu'à l'ordinaire
avec effectivement la gestion en plus
des affaires courantes et en même temps
lui demander effectivement d'être dans
une zone de zéro risque parce que on
imagine bien que cela se ferait aux
dépens de l'exercice de ses fonctions
donc je ne crois pas qu'on puisse jeter
la pierre à nos dirigeants de contracter
le coc vide parce que finalement ils
sont plutôt courageux il s'expose plus
que nous effectivement au risque compte
tenu des réunions qu'ils doivent tenir
compte tenu des enjeux qu'ils doivent
continuer à assumer et finalement ça
n'est pas étonnant que
on apprenne que nos dirigeants que ce
soit effectivement le premier ministre
anglais où que ce soit aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron et bien que aussi
finissent par être contaminé ça dit
aussi que décidément tout le monde peut
se contaminer parce qu'on imagine que
ces chefs d'état très protégé notamment
par des services de sécurité toute la
journée autour de hors jeu parle aussi
de donald trump de boris johnson et bien
finalement ils contractent le virus avec
autant de facilité
est ce que la population ne veut pas
tout simplement se dire que voilà c'est
très compliqué de l'éviter ce virus
qu'on peut l'attraper même si d'une
certaine manière on se protège parce
qu'on imagine bien qu emmanuel macron a
dû forcément être protégés et se
protéger oui vous avez vraiment raison
ce qui caractérise avant tout ce virus
avant sa dangerosité qui est finalement
somme toute quand même encore à un
niveau acceptable c'est sa contagiosité
on a annoncé une contagiosité de trois à
quatre fois supérieur à la grippe mais
c'est exactement ce qu'on constate et
s'il est difficile d'échapper à la
grippe
s'il est parfois facile d'échapper la
grippe il s'avère extrêmement difficile
d'échapper dans le temps au courant d'un
virus l'espagne a malheureusement la
situation s'aggrave chez vous également
parle de ce long week-end férié qui
pourrait en être la cause
est-ce que la proche des fêtes de
famille vous en tant que médecin vous
vous inquiète particulièrement non
écoutez je trouve finalement que tout
cela finalement fait perdre un peu la
tête parce que on savait très bien
effectivement que la perspective des
fêtes de noël et des fêtes de fin
d'année entraînerait une hausse à
nouveau des contaminations et
constituerait une zone de l'année à
risque mais on sait aussi que l'année
2020 que nous venons de vivre a été
excessivement difficile pour pour la
population et que effectivement
aujourd'hui se dire qu'on va clôturer
l'année comme on l'a vécu c'est à dire
avec un taux de restriction maximum
et bien c'est difficile à accepter c'est
difficile à accepter
et donc aujourd'hui évidemment on voit
remonter un petit peu les taux de
contaminations à barcelone ou à madrid
mais enfin on est quand même kaka 200
quintaux de 200 contamination pour
100000 habitants ce qui est pas non plus
extraordinaire et finalement on se
demande
on se demande où est la cohérence dans
tout ça parce que on avait accepté de
relâcher un petit peu la pression
justement pour redonner un petit peu
plus d espace de vie à la population
tout en sachant pertinemment de toute
façon qu'on ne peut pas je dirais
converger vers un risque zéro
or le confinement total et général est
aujourd'hui évidemment ça remonte un peu
mais c'est pas une surprise et
finalement eh ben on trouve comme
solution de dire d'un va effectivement
verrouiller les sept
alors il ya aussi vous disiez barcelone
évidemment madrid mais l'île de majorque
était jusqu'ici épargné les maintenant
toucher la faute justement entre
guillemets assez à ses touristes
ces vacanciers n'ont écouté c'est tout à
fait prévisible parce que ce à quoi on a
assisté à barcelone par exemple c'est
que les gens ont décidé d'aller se
mettre au vert et finalement il y avait
très peu de choix pour par exemple pour
les gens qui habitent à barcelone
c'était soit majorque soit les canaris
est effectivement moi dans mon entourage
j'ai vu un certain nombre effectivement
d'amis de patients partira meilleur
partir aux canaries et donc on a eu une
espèce d'arrivée de concentration
effectivement de personnes dans 16 il
est très logiquement
eh bien ça a nourri effectivement une
aggravation du taux de contamination
aujourd'hui dr emmanuelli la seule issue
finalement c'est le vaccin vous êtes aux
petits ni optimiste confiant justement
sur les premières réactions vaccins et
vaccination pardon je vais dire à yves
et qui doivent intervenir le 27 décembre
en europe
oui alors écoutez la difficulté c'est
qu'il n'y a pas d' analyse ni noire ni
blanche c'est à dire que d'un côté on a
effectivement cette épidémie qui n'en
finit plus avec en plus des mutations
qui sont annoncés en angleterre depuis
quelques jours qui touche justement la
structure du virus contre lequel le
vaccin doit agir donc d'un côté on sent
bien qu'il ya urgence à agir si on ne
veut pas retomber dans un scénario noir
où couraient après épidémie et puis de
l'autre côté il y à ces vaccins et
notamment ce vaccin arn qui il faut le
dire je me suis penchée sur les textes
scientifiques parce qu'en conscience
comme médecin d'abord je veux savoir si
je vais me vacciner et je veux savoir ce
que je peux conseiller la population en
tout cas en confiance est ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que ce vaccin qui nous
est proposé c'est un pas de géant ça
correspond effectivement
scientifiquement à la conquête de la
lune
on est vraiment sur une prouesse
scientifique absolument incroyable on ne
dit pas assez mais c'est une révolution
mais de l'autre côté et c'est bien pour
ça aujourd'hui qu'il ya une réticence
dans la population
de l'autre côté on fait un pas dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le transhumanisme
c'est à dire un petit peu cette tendance
à faire de l'homme un super homme qui
est en vogue aux états unis depuis vingt
ans et on flirte avec le transhumanisme
parce que vraiment on flirte avec
effectivement la question du génome chez
l'homme même si la rn ne rentre pas dans
la cellule même si effectivement il
disparaît au bout de 15 minutes pour la
première fois peut-être dans l'humanité
on va faire fabriquer par l'homme
artificiellement une molécule étrangères
au corps
justement c'est quelque chose vous le
décrivez très bien qui est très innovant
qu'on connaît mal le scepticisme est il
aussi fort en espagne qu'en france
quant à la vaccination alors le débat
est moins important en espagne à la
population espagnole est assez pro
vaccin donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas le
débat dans la même intensité que que
qu'en france et puis surtout c'est moins
un sujet médiatique c'est à dire que
c'est moi un sujet de débat même dans
les médias merci à vous philippe
emmanuel y médecins français exerçant à
barcelone d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et outre atlantique
à présent les etats-unis confrontés
depuis plus d'un mois également un
spectaculaire rebond de l'épidémie le
pays a enregistré hier son plus lourd
bilan
plus de 3700 morts et 250 milles 4 kobe
de 19 en une seule journée selon les
chiffres de l'université johns hopkins
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées est
également au plus haut le point sur la
situation sanitaire avec cyrielle
benavides bill polian des chiffres
inédits qui ne faiblissent pas plus de
3700 morts et 250 mille cas de co vite
19 ont été enregistrés aux états unis en
une seule journée indiquent les chiffres
de l'université johns hopkins et 113
mille personnes sont toujours
hospitalisées à cause du virus
d'après le ministère américain de la
santé des records dans le pays ces deux
dernières semaines qui s'expliquerait
selon les responsables sanitaires par la
traditionnelle fête de fin
giving des millions d'américains avaient
rendu visite à leurs proches se
déplaçant à travers le pays
une situation qui pourrait perdurer à
l'occasion des fêtes de noël mais les
politiques américains gardent espoir
grâce au vaccin
kaiser
qui a fait son entrée dans le pays ce
lundi après des mois de difficultés nous
avons marqué l'histoire
hier sous l'opération war speed avec le
premier vaccin contre le coronavirus
administrés dans les états de tout le
pays
je suis impatient de recevoir le vaccin
moi même dans les jours à venir et vous
encourage à le faire sans hésitation les
américains peuvent être convaincus que
même si nous avançons plus vite que l'
agence des médicaments ne l'a jamais
fait nous n'avons littéralement
compromis aucune norme de sécurité
le vice président a précisé qu'il le
ferait en public ce vendredi accompagné
de sa femme karen avec cette action il
souhaite renforcer la confiance des
américains
si l'ancien président barack obama et le
futur président joe biden compte emboîté
le pas de mike pence
donald trump lui n'a pas prévu de se
faire vacciner pour le moment on tunisie
la colère gronde toujours après à
mohamed bouazizi en 2010 un autre jeune
homme omar s'est immolé par le feu à
regueb près de sidi bouzid
il n'a pas survécu à ses blessures
l'histoire se répète des manifestations
ont eu lieu à l'occasion des 10 ans au
début de la révolution qu'on a appelé
les printemps arabes
[Applaudissements]
l'absence du président de la république
du chef du gouvernement et celle du
président de l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple n'a qu'une seule
explication ils n'ont pas tenu leurs
promesses
donc ils n'osent plus nous confronter
nous ne ferons pas la fête nous sommes
en deuil depuis dix ans chaque année
sidi bouzid clore sa révolution ces
hommes et ces martyrs les avocats sont
aujourd'hui présents tout d'abord pour
soutenir la foule opprimés pour insister
sur le fait que la partie est menacée et
dire que ceci représente une ligne rouge
que nous ne permettons à personne de
franchir nous ferons tout pour faire
face à toute tentative de destruction de
l'état ou encore d'atteinte à ses acquis
alors que reste-t-il aujourd'hui à de la
révolution du jasmin les explications de
nadège abderrazak 7 et il ya dix ans
jour pour jour le 17 décembre 2010
du côté de sidi bouzid dans le centre de
la tunisie mohamed bouazizi vendeur
ambulant de fruits et légumes s'immole
par le feu après s'être fait confisquer
sa marchandise par des policiers est cet
acte désespéré de ce jeune homme de 26
ans et déclencheur du printemps arabe
s'ensuivra des semaines de
manifestations marquées par des émeutes
sanglantes aux quatre coins du pays
une colère dirigée contre le président
au pouvoir depuis 23 ans avec pour seul
mot d'ordre benali dégage mais c'est
inadmissible
on en a plein le cul de lui de ses
conneries on veut qu'ils dégagent qu'il
dégage merde qu'il dégage est que nos
prêts et que les prisonniers d'opinion
dans cet établissement même derrière
vous qui sont libérés ils sont en train
of thought de se faire torturer
pourquoi parce qu'ils se sont exprimés
franchement on veut que ben ali quitte
le pouvoir
ça fait au moins 300 38 morts et plus de
2000 blessés
cette révolution du jasmin comme on se
plaît à la qualifier a eu raison du
président ben ali qui prendra la fuite
le 14 janvier 2011
mais qu'en est il aujourd'hui que
reste-t-il des espoirs qui avaient
émergé à l'époque une révolution prend
du temps et elle est souvent semée
d'embûches en politique par exemple la
tunisie a connu en une décennie 9
exécutif dans certains n'ont tenu que
quelques mois encore aux la difficulté
de s'entendre pour les deux forces
politiques majeures du pays laïcs et
islamistes
le dernier gouvernement date est celui
dit chen li shishi ancien ministre de
l'intérieur
approuvé en septembre par le parlement
il est composé de juges d'universitaires
de fonctionnaires et de cadres du privé
je suis fier de ce soutien le
gouvernement va pouvoir avancer sur les
problèmes économiques du moment qu'ils
ne se retrouvent pris dans aucun
tiraillements politiques et des
problèmes économiques la tunisie en
collectionne depuis dix ans la
croissance a diminué de moitié depuis
2010 le chômage pointes à plus de 16%
il est endémique chez les jeunes
puisqu'ils représentent 85 % des
demandeurs d'emploi le dinar la monnaie
tunisienne a perdu 40% de sa valeur et
la dette du pays a quadruplé elle
atteint désormais 100 milliards de
dinars soit plus de 30 milliards d'euros
la pandémie de kobe 19 a fini par mettre
l'économie tunisienne à genoux martin
autre que le terme
on est tous fatigués pourquoi parce que
tout à augmenter les conditions de vie
sont plus difficiles
qu'il ya dix ans en a fait une
révolution pour abords du mieux on a le
pire
tout a augmenté c'est devenu difficile
pour nous on n'en peut plus notre
salaire arrive et il repart aussi vite
on s'en rend même pas compte de la
liberté à l'extérieur tu sens qu'il ya
eu du changement avec le système avec
town chose tu la sens la liberté mais
elle m'a servi à rien je pense qu'à
partir quitter le pays clandestinement
ce qu'on a entendu pendant la révolution
il n'en est rien sorti pas de travail
pas de liberté en farsi de la liberté
mais pas de la liberté et libertés plus
une liberté de symbole
ce qui compte c'est la liberté du
citoyen c'est travailler moi je suis au
chômage situation tout aussi compliquée
sur le plan social face à la flambée des
prix le centre et le sud du pays
connaissent régulièrement de violentes
émeutes
pour tenter de mieux vivre de survivre
et des dizaines de milliers de tunisiens
tentent chaque année de rejoindre
l'europe souvent au péril de leur vie
alors si la plupart des tunisiens estime
aujourd'hui être plus libre que sous
l'ère ben ali
le sentiment de déception et d'amertume
reste très présent chez ceux qui
attendait bien mieux d'une démocratie et
pour en parler nous sommes avec hatem un
f6 essayiste auteur de tunisie
dessine-moi une révolution éditions de
l'harmattan
bonsoir à thème un f6 merci d'être avec
nous quand on entend la colère de ces
tunisiens la colère voilà les plus
jeunes des moins jeunes on se dit tout
ça pour ça disent ans après que
reste-t-il
et bien ce qu'il reste c'est comme ça a
été soulignée la liberté d'expression et
ce n'est pas un vain mot
cette semaine par exemple une télévision
va proposer à des jeunes de débattre de
si la révolution prend le bon chemin ou
lourd et chemin c'est quelque chose qui
est juste inenvisageable dans les autres
pays qui ont connu une première vague
des printemps arabes
donc ça c'est très important en revanche
il ya une instabilité politique qui a
fait qu' il n'était pas possible
d'apporter les solutions un gouvernement
dur en moyenne un an
on ne peut pas changer le modèle de
développement ne peut pas mettre une
politique économique et sociale en moins
d'un an
si on est obligé de d'effacer de
recommencer à chaque fois et donc
forcément là on a un petit recul on
s'arrête on fait un point d'étape
on se dit qu'effectivement en dix ans la
situation économique et sociale à au
moins stagné si ce n'est empiré et il
n'y a rien eu de
fondamental dans le changement du modèle
social il ya toujours les mêmes
disparités entre les régions où sein
même des régions entre les centres des
métropoles et la ceinture populaire ça
n'a pas changé les gens s'impatientent
ça fait dix ans que la ville efficiente
circulairement dur mais justement c'est
terrible ce constat parce que c'est vrai
que voilà tout le monde s'émerveille et
beaucoup de volants de médias
occidentaux je disais voilà c'était
formidable cette révolution et quel est
le message et ça dit quoi
parce qu on les entendait dire on lave
c'est pire aujourd'hui
qu est ce qu on en retient pour quelles
raisons alors justement l'aller les
tunisiens se cherche et d'ailleurs le
cto l'enseignement du secourisme des
deux scrutins qui a eu en 2019
c'est à dire que autant ils ont
reconduit les mêmes personnes aux
législatives et donc les mêmes
les mêmes causes produisant les mêmes
conséquences on a reproduit les mêmes
donc forcément les mêmes tiraillements
politiques les mêmes les mêmes batailles
d'ego et les mêmes faux problème qui
empêche de d'attaquer les problématiques
économiques et sociales autant ils ont
tenté aussi l' aventure passée sarid en
se disant on va prendre quelqu'un qui
est totalement hors du entre guillemets
du système politique
et force est de constater qu'un an après
un essai sarrail et s'il reste très
populaire n'a pas fait grand-chose
contenu déjà de ses faibles prérogatives
mais même dans ses prérogatives il s'est
cantonné à
des discours mais sans acte aujourd'hui
n'a pas pu se rendre à sidi bouzid c'est
terrible il a promis aux gens de sidi
bouzid de venir et il n'est pas venu
donc il donc là il se cherche
aujourd'hui les sondages d'opinion pour
les législatives continua pour la
présidentielle on continue à plébisciter
retard ça s'arrête mais pour les
législatives en plébiscite là si vous
voulez l'icône de l'ancien régime arabi
et le moci qui se présente comme une
digne héritière de du système qui a été
déchu et qui propose de refermer cette
cette parenthèse de la révolution sans
alors qu'elle oublie de dire que les
gens se sont révoltés aussi contre ce
système donc aujourd'hui il ya une
nostalgie d'une vie moins chère de moins
d'insécurité mais en même temps si les
gens sont révoltés il ya dix ans et que
ça allait mal aussi
donc on est un petit peu dans l'impasse
et et voilà donc il ya beaucoup de
mouvements sociaux qui s'y qui secoue le
pays et qui font que voilà on se cherche
on essaye de trouver une solution mais
il me semble difficile que les gens
veuillent par contre renoncé aux
libertés qui ont obtenu puisque
aujourd'hui peuvent exprimer leur
mécontentement dans la rue donc qui a
effectivement il demande d'ordre mais en
même temps on veut pas renoncer à cette
liberté
merci merci à thème nafti essayiste
auteur de tunisie dessine-moi une
révolution merci à vous et avant de
clore cette émission un anniversaire le
nôtre celui d'arte et france déjà trois
ans et oui demain jour pour jour que
nous vivons cette aventure pleine de
défis notre arrivée dans le paysage
médiatique français a été scruté
commenté souvent critiqué mais aussi
parfois saluer et souvent d'ailleurs
nous travaillons tous les jours pour
vous offrir une information complète
fiable et vous donner des opinions
diverses et la parole à ceux qui n'ont
pas nécessairement je tenais à féliciter
toutes nos équipes au nom d' art et
franche les journalistes de la direction
de la rédaction pardon à les reporter
sur le terrain les équipes techniques
évidemment je remercie également toutes
les personnes qui nous suivent depuis le
début
et celles qui nous ont rejoints en cours
de route merci donc pour votre fidélité
et bon anniversaire à rt france bonsoir
à tous au nom de toute la rédaction je
suis très fier et très heureuse de vous
accueillir pour ce tout premier journal
der t france des organes d'un flux ans
de propagande et de propagande
mensongère goudé montreuil pour le
château
alors non mais vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve dans quelques minutes
pour 1 point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]